over the past decade no legal scholar
has pushed Arguments for free speech as
far or as influentially as Jeff casf a
former journalist who now teaches cyber
security law at the US Naval Academy in
previous books he defended section 230
of the communications decency act as the
26 words that created the internet and
he stood up for anonymous speech in the
United States of anonymous how the First
Amendment shaped online speech his new
book is its boldest yet it's called liar
in a crowded theater freedom of speech
in a world of misinformation and I liked
it so much that I blurbed It calling it
a smart Ry deeply researched and utterly
convincing defense of legal protections
for misinformation in an age when we are
less likely to agree on basic facts than
ever before I talk with kasf about why
misinformation however it gets defined
should be protected how the boundaries
between private companies and government
actors are getting blurrier and blurrier
and why so many journalists are calling
for limits on the First
Amendment Jeff kasf thanks for talking
to Reza thanks so much for having me all
right so uh let's start with the
elevator pitch for liar in a crowded
Theater which has uh not only well you
have a bunch of questionable blurbs on
the book one of which I provided but
what a great cover and title liar in a
credit theater and it's a fire alarm
that says liar in a crowded Theater
what's the elevator pitch so there are a
lot of concerns about misinformation
some that are very legitimate some that
I think might be overhyped but
regardless of that this there have been
so many solutions that have started with
the premise of overhauling the First
Amendment and what my book sets out to
do is to say let's just slow down a
little bit and let's look at why the
First Amendment exists why it protects a
lot of falsehoods and alleged falsehoods
and other solutions to these concerns
that don't automatically involve giving
government off you are like a real
Troublemaker saying like oh maybe the
first amendment is worth something uh in
today's climate in a in a broad sense
well I I didn't really think that this
was something that I needed to write
about but especially since I've been
doing a lot of the press for this book
it's been really a little disheartening
how many journalists have been sort of
both siding the First Amendment and I I
think there's a lot of debate about both
siding but for the First Amendment for
journalists I feel like you could be Pro
First Amendment and it's okay like we
get it I mean you're a you're a former
journalist an awardwinning journalist un
I am an award losing journalist you're
an award-winning journalist that's among
the many differences um and this book is
of a piece with your previous work which
included uh a defense of section 230
when that was really starting to come
under a lot of attack that seems to have
abated a little bit and then your
previous book uh was about Anonymous
speech defending Anonymous speech so um
I guess before we go into the meat of
the book like you you you were a
journalist but like what is wrong with
you that you are consistently defending
the First Amendment across these large
you know kind of waves of criticism of
it whether it's the you know things
related to section 230 and online speech
Anonymous speech and now misinformation
yeah so a lot of what I find myself
doing is defending the status quo which
uh because the United States we have a
lot of problems with a lot of our laws
but I think the first amendment is
actually one of the bright spots of our
Constitution and it sets us apart for
most of the rest of the world so a lot
the overall theme that I have is let's
actually look at why we have these
protections and yes there are problems
but let's not impulsively react to this
by saying let's scrap all of this and
become like Europe or Russia I I don't
think that's a great solution yeah it's
um kind of amazing I I turned 60 over
the summer and I mistook the time and I
guess this is very common the time that
I grew up in was oh that's just the way
it always has been and as I got older i
s you know I realized like the first
amendment really wasn't that strong or
robust or it wasn't interpreted and it
didn't have a lot of cultural Force
really until the postwar era in a big
way and then it seemed to be getting
better and better through the '90s there
were obviously a lot of fights about
online speech and other forms of kind of
unfettered expression in the 90s which
ultimately got beaten back but it is
it's stunning to me you mentioned
journalists both sides in the First
Amendment like it it's you know because
you realize the First Amendment doesn't
have to be interpreted the way it is or
the way it has been for most of our
Lives you're what in your mid-40s yeah
um what do you just very briefly what do
you think is going on with journalists
where they are like ah I don't know you
know like maybe the first amendment is
is kind of problematic I think there's a
lot of comfort uh I think that Mo most
journalists in America have not
experienced a system without the First
Amendment so it's easier to take it for
granted and I I think that's the best
case scenario some of my experience as a
journalist has been I I've actually
relied on the First Amendment both both
with having a member of Congress
threaten a defamation lawsuit and a very
powerful person in Texas threatened to
use local officials to arrest me for
publishing material so for me it I I see
the real value in why we have the First
Amendment and in a lot of other
countries I could have been sued out of
existence or gone to jail yeah and that
was uh disturbing when uh uh Donald
Trump first uh kind of was running for
for president in 2016 one of the early
kind of brash statements he said is like
I'm going to open up the Lial
laws um and uh yeah you don't want you
don't want politicians doing that right
no you don't and we have at least two
justices on the Supreme Court who say we
should revisit opening up the Lial laws
and undercutting really one of the most
important protections for journalist so
which again only really dates back to
the what the early 60s yeah 1964 and I
think journalists would in the United
States would have a very different
experience doing their job if we didn't
have that protection so let's start with
the uh kind of controlling metaphor and
joke in the title liar in a credit
theater that's a reference to you know
people who will constantly say including
law professors journalists politicians
who say you cannot you know free speech
is great but you can't yell fire in a
crowded theater uh just unpack that a
little bit what what is that phrase you
know where is it coming from and why are
people getting it so wrong so contrary
to popular belief the Supreme Court
never had a case actually involving a
fire in a crowded theater but they did
use a derivative of that phrase and this
was in
1919 there was a socialist in
Philadelphia named Charles shank who was
Distributing Flyers outside on the
street corner that made a very bad legal
argument it said that the military draft
violates the 13th Amendment it it was
stupid but he was arrested under the
Sedition Act for posing a clear and
present danger to the US military
efforts and now you would think that's
crazy but at the time the court was very
permissive so in a unanimous opinion
Justice Oliver Wendel Holmes upheld his
conviction and just sort of as an
off-hand metaphor said you can't just as
you can't falsely yell fire in a theater
and cause a panic you also can't do this
you can't leaflet stupid pamphlets like
Broad and uh you know Spring Street or
something in uh in Philadelphia exactly
and and that metaphor quickly took off
and I actually had a very boring title
for the book for the first half of my
research and I changed it because what I
found time and again as I was
researching cases where the government
or private parties tried to restrict
speech and it would later get struck
down when they were trying to restrict
the speech they would almost always use
fire in a crowded theater say because
you can't yell fire in a crowded theater
you can't say x y or Z when you usually
can say x y or Z so and of course you
can I mean in Holmes's quote it's that
you can't falsely do it right and you
can't incite like a trampling or
something like that but if there's a
fire you you talk about in the book like
if you're in a play and somebody in the
play has to say fire obviously that's
okay um so that's this shank decision in
1917 and that came came up with uh what
is it the uh clear and present danger
test right so it's like that pamphlet by
you know a nuta Kami in you know just
after World War I that was interpreted
as being like Oh that could bring the
whole thing down so we have to shut it
down because it's clear and present
danger um two years later there's the
Abrams case excuse me um can you explain
what the Abrams case is which Holmes is
also involved in and how does that kind
of reiterate or revise the yeah so both
cases were actually decided in 1919 so
this there was about 9 month space so
the sup so uh Abrams was in March and
then the Supreme Court takes a nice long
recess and during the summer and during
that time uh Holmes goes back home to
Massachusetts and he spends a lot of
time with some fairly uh libertarian uh
Harvard Law professors who basically say
to him hey you know that fire in a
crowed theater thing that that really is
dangerous and they gave him readings
from John Stewart Mill and Milton and
they really changed his mind Thomas hey
a law professor at Sean Hall has a great
book called The Great descent which goes
through that summer so Holmes gets back
that fall and he gets a very similar
case called um called Abrams where uh
almost identical to shank and uh this
time the Supreme Court 7 to2 upholds the
conviction but Holmes joined by brandise
descends what what are the facts of the
case PR it's basically criticizing uh US
military policy in Russia and it's a
brochure that's criticizing it it's all
almost identical arguments uh and so you
would think that Holmes would come out
the same way and he tries to distinguish
shank and say this is a little different
but then in his descent it's I think
it's the most quoted descent in Supreme
Court history he articulates this
Marketplace of ideas metaphor the idea
that rather than
immediately regulating speech it's
better to let truth and falsity grapple
on the open market and uh let let truth
Prevail and it's just this radically
different Theory than he had just
articulated six months ago but it's it's
it's I mean a a really great metaphor
and it that goes back to Milton uh as
well as John Stewart Mill later but
Milton um can you talk a little bit
about that origin of the idea uh I mean
and this is really at the beginning of a
kind of liberal conception of governance
as well as speech and Society uh you
know what like that you know these
people who uh who are out there who are
reading stuff might be capable of
actually figuring things out on their
own yeah and you see this throughout a
lot of uh writings for centuries that um
first the regulation uh often isn't all
that effective so toille wrote uh quite
a bit about what I what I think actually
has evolved into the Strand effect which
is that if you're regulating speech it's
actually going to get more attention uh
because people will pay attention to why
is the government doing this so it might
actually and you see that today um one
one thing I like to point out is um all
of the people who were really uh
thrilled about Trump getting
deplatformed from Twitter a lot of the
more liberal journalists and they really
said this is the best decision ever um
now you see them routinely uh
screenshotting what he posts on Truth
social and drawing attention and it's
like you're you're bringing more
attention to it rather than if you just
let him talk and so I mean I think
that's a big part of the marketplace as
well so then the the next step in this
is uh kind of uh Brandenburg right which
is 1969 what are the facts of that case
and how does that kind of act as a Koda
to the original shank decision
so that was um under Ohio's criminal
syndicalism law it was a KKK leader who
was um who who was uh being convicted
and he was challenging his conviction
under the First Amendment the government
said you know this is a clear and
present danger just like shank just like
Abrams and the court doesn't explicitly
overrule shank and Abrams but it
basically says well what we really meant
was it's not a clear and present danger
the standard is imminent incitement of
Lawless action so both that um the
person speaking intended to cause
imminent Lawless action and they would
have had a likely effect of doing so
which is totally different than saying
it's a clear and present danger that's
so much harder to meet so they
effectively narrowed quite a bit the
standard that Holmes had first
articulated is that the same as fighting
words or is it slightly no those are
those are different and fighting words
is not not all that often used but the
this so imminent incitement is something
that the government would rely on more
what's a what's a good example like or
the you know the textbook example of uh
imminent in incitement
to so it's obviously very fact specific
but if you had a mob of people who were
protesting a business and you're outside
the business and you're saying this is
the way into the business and this is
how we're going to destroy the property
and physically injure people and let's
go now that it has to be that sort of
level it's not just saying you know I
don't I I think this business is corrupt
or that it's stealing from its workers
what if you say something like we should
take this business down and then people
start riding is I mean how much of it is
predicated upon what happens as opposed
to what is spoken well so it's it has
both a subjective and objective
component so you still have to show did
the person intend to to do this and that
that's really gonna so in that like with
Trump on January 6th is he uh you know
is do in your opinion do you think is he
guilty of incitement per se uh you know
I'm going to pass on that for now
because I I I think for I I try not to
talk about politicians given my given my
current job but oh that's right yeah
you're part of the problem right you're
part of the government so okay so well
let's talk so that's kind the backdrop
and then we're talking about
misinformation you opened the book with
the pizza gate shooting um can you talk
remind us of a few of the details and
then how does that like why did you
start the book with the pizz gate
shooting yeah so I started with pizza
gate because that was really the origin
of so so much concern about fake news uh
obviously when you hear fake news now
it's associated with complaints about
the media but really the modern fake
news debate started in 2016 with
concerns about Russia and concerns about
people on social media making up stories
and it kind of got intertwined with the
wiki Wikileaks uh and the hack the hack
of podesta and so for pizza G you know
I'm sorry to interrupt it's like that is
not long ago and it kind of seems like I
don't even remember that season you know
that's like when the Happy Days team
like you know started a dude ranch or
something like I you know I don't know
yeah no it does feel like a lifetime ago
um and so when podesta's emails were
hacked there they they're kind of
trickled out and there was one
communication about a fundraiser at uh
we're we're we're in DC right now uh
just a few miles away in Chevy Chase uh
there's a pizza restaurant that podesta
had an email with the owner of the pizza
restaurant it's a family pizza place
yeah pizza and ping pong yeah yeah and
um so
somehow there on sort of the conspiracy
parts of the internet there were
theories about um it about this being
sort of a
nefarious uh business and it sort of
devolved into these claims these very
false claims that um Democrats were
running a satanic child sex trafficking
ring from the basement of Comet Ping
Pong even though it didn't even have a
basement history repeats itself uh I
don't know like At first as farce uh
because I when I when that story was
unfolding I was thinking about in um
peewee's big adventure when he's looking
for the basement in the Alamo and there
like there is no basement here it starts
as farce and ends as tragedy because a
deranged guy shows up and shot up Comet
Pizza yeah yeah and I mean for
fortunately nobody was physically
injured but it was obviously terrifying
for the employees the customers and uh I
I think that it was really interesting
to trace that case uh he ended up be uh
pleading guilty and being sentenced by
then District Judge katangi Brown
Jackson and what never happened to her I
don't know well she had her own
experience with misinformation that I
talk about in the book um but she during
sentencing she said you know you
obviously I feel very badly for you but
I'm going to sentence you to four years
in prison because it's not really an
excuse that you bought into the
conspiracy theories and actually she
handled it very well think that's how
you deal with misinformation is don't
treat people like these sort of passive
recipients and if you're going to
believe nonsense on the internet and act
on it then you face consequences yeah I
mean in the marketplace of ideas it's
got to be Cav admor right exactly yeah
and and that is I mean I don't think
this is a hard cell to me I hope it
isn't to other people but yeah that's
the whole idea like we're not passive
consumers of media whether it's TV shows
or news or anything like we you know the
individual is ultimately constructing
the meaning so they should be held
responsible for really bad
interpretations well but unfortunately I
think there's a whole lot of people
including members of Congress who
disagree with that who think that
individuals have really no control over
how they respond and they're just
programmed by misinformation this is
yeah now I I working on a different
piece that revisits in the 90s this was
obviously a massive kind of battleground
of our TV viewers Janet Reno the
Attorney General under B under Bill
Clinton was threatening networks both
cable and broadcast saying you have to
reduce violence um or else I will censor
you and and her governing Theory which
was widely shared by liberals and
conservatives was that people are
passive consumers of entertainment and
we get programmed by this stuff so you
know we need the guardian class and that
was kind of what was great about the
internet Revolution really was like no
thanks we're the end user is in charge
here I you know I I create my meaning
but sorry to go off on that so uh so
then um you
know uh talk a little bit about the
katani uh Brown Jackson um
misinformation her problem with
misinformation so this was during her
confirmation hearings for the Supreme
Court uh Senator Holly in a few days
before her hearings he tweeted out a
long Thread about um you know real
concerns that he had about her
sentencing of people who shared child
sex abuse material or who downloaded it
and there are very strict federal laws
that uh had and the sentencing
guidelines are very very high for this
and um he said you know in seven cas
cases she sentence below the guidelines
which judges have the ability to do um
and it was all factually accurate what
what he did um but the way that he
presented it made it seem like she was
this radical judge who wanted to let
child Predators free and it provided no
context that the majority of federal
judges in non-production child
pornography cases senten below the
guidelines because they're so high and
so I
but then sort of in a lot of sort of
Niche media Outlets it became you know
why is katanu brown Jackson uh easy on
child predators and it became really
something she had she had to deal with
but she did deal with it I think she
during her hearing she exercised what we
would call counter speech and she
explained you know I take these
incredibly seriously and this is how I
address it um but I mean is what Holly
did misinformation I don't know I don't
know what the definition misinformation
is bad information right but and it's
motivated information but we shouldn't
regulate it I mean he that's what
politicians do and I use sort of the
other example of Adam Schiff and Adam
Schiff made a lot of statements during
the house investigation about Trump with
Russia and he I mean he he was
not he he was he was giving his opinion
which he's allowed to do but I mean some
of what he said made it seem like he
knew more than what was in the record so
and which has not come out that I mean
Russia gate uh and I guess we should
specify what we mean when we say Russia
gate like I'm thinking about it in terms
of the idea that there was an act of
collusion between the uh Putin
government or you know agents of
influence and Donald Trump for during
the 2016 election and that um you know
that has never been proven even you know
by the government by anybody who's
investigated it so that's another like
big meatball of Mis
misinformation um how you know discuss a
little bit how that you know those
charges of Russian
collusion play out in in kind of the
misinformation ecosystem well so I mean
I I think just like with Holly for for
shift there shouldn't be any regulation
on what he said if you regulate it every
time politici
sort of showcased their version of The
Facts you wouldn't have politicians
anymore I mean that's what they do and
so ultimately it's a political issue
it's it's you know if the
voters don't like it then the voters
will speak but I don't think you should
have courts getting involved in I either
of those cases or any anything other
than these narrow exceptions to the
first amendment that the Supreme Court's
articulated and neither of those come
anywhere close to that um you write
about uh Governor Jay Insley of
Washington who this you know so if we
have like there's the pizzagate stuff
and you know and and kind of related to
that is qanon and there's that whole
wave which I hope has kind of crested
and is receded for good about you know
kind of grooming because there was also
the Wayfair case that the idea that
somehow Wayfair the online you
know what furniture store and stuff was
selling
children yeah you know Etc and I mean
this was like in wide circulation and
stuff like that but you know there's
that there's the Russia gate uh stuff
but then Insley is talking about another
thing uh as governor of Washington he
wanted to regulate people who were
essentially meaning Donald Trump who you
know is kind of a frustrating figure
because he's he's at every interes of
this type of stuff right he was the
object of the Russia gate collusion uh
charges but then he won't shut up about
how no election even his win in 2016 he
hasn't acknowledged that that was a
legitimate election um but Insley wanted
to uh criminalize people who deny
election results right can you talk
about that and why you know why
shouldn't you be able to shut people up
who keep delegitimating elections yeah
so on the one-year anniversary of
January 6th he announced his support for
a bill that would would uh basically
lead to a gross misdemeanor con uh
charge which is up to a year in prison
uh for any political candidate or
elected official who um challenges the
administration of an election that's
been adjudicated to be administered
fairly so if someone were to say you
know after an election is certified that
this election was stolen that could as
long as they met certain intent
requirements um that could lead to these
criminal charges and uh it had the
Brandenburg imminent incitement as one
of three ways that you could face
liability but there were other there
were other ways as well um of course
when he announced his support he said
just like you can't yell fire in a
crowded theater because of course you've
got to say that yeah and um it
fortunately it got a hearing and then it
fortunately died in committee because I
think enough Democrats and Republicans
said we we can't do this and I I think
that if you step back and even if you
set aside the concerns about how a
prosecutor could easily abuse this to
just go after political opponents um how
effective is that going to be because
will the general public trust elections
more if they know that you've got any
prosecutor in the state being able to
jail politicians I mean that's like that
I mean I mean that's really some like
Banana Republic stuff that we're dealing
with here like that we we can't do that
that but just the fact that we had a
governor of a state saying that that
that's really concerning yeah um the you
know I when I was reading that section
it reminded me I guess it was in
2018 whenever uh one of the times that
Mark Zuckerberg came and and testified
before Congress and he talked at that
point he was kind of in his Free Speech
mode because he's always toggling back
and forth and he said that he was not
going to police a lot of political
speech including things like Holocaust
deniers because it's like you know it it
it takes too much time and it's not
effective and it's better to have that
stuff out there and have counter speech
and he there was some discussion he had
with Alexander oeso Cortez who ran who
asked a pretty good question where she
said well what about people who say the
election is on this day and misir people
like where it's the day after the
election or it's someplace else and he
didn't really have a good answer to that
like is that the type of misinformation
that should be actionable well so the
Supreme Court actually um said in
passing in a footnote but it's still a
supreme court opinion that um it is it
might be possible for the government to
regulate uh law intentional falsehoods
about the mechanics of voting so not not
whether something was an election was
administered fairly but saying the
elections on Wednesday or saying you
know go to the polling place that's not
actually your polling place so the court
has at least suggested that that would
be an exception and would that also
include saying like oh you you uh can
vote by mail if you can't or like text
this number any anything that would
misdirect people I think it would I mean
we it's it's a one sentence footnote in
a supreme court opinion but uh I think
the trickier thing and we were're deal
there are some cases out there right now
uh what if someone's joking and this is
a whole if I had the time to write a
book about it I would which is the first
amendment in humor because um the court
I mean going back to the Hustler and
Jerry fwell case the court has protected
humor but a lot of it depends on how
would a reasonable person interpret that
humor so would someone if you're s if
you're saying the elections on Wednesday
some people might actually take it
seriously even if it was intended as a
joke right
um let's um talk about uh Javier Alvarez
uh who was he and why is he uh mentioned
in your book yeah so I'll just say in my
opinion I should probably caveat
everything that I say in this interview
is not the opinion of the defense
department it's just mine or the US Navy
or even most of your family members no
one wants to take credit for anything I
say um but uh so he was not a very nice
very honest person um he was a local
water commissioner in the Claremont
California area he was elected in 2006
he has his first meeting in 2007 and
they asked the members to introduce
themselves and he stands up and says I'm
a retired Marine I received the
Congressional Medal of Honor which is
the highest honor that you could receive
in the military only about 3,500 people
in US history have received it um and he
says you know I'm still around and other
than still being around it was all a lie
he never served in the military so he
obviously never received the
Congressional Medal of Honor but a few
years earlier unfortunately for him uh
Congress had passed a law called The
Stolen Valor Act which says that if you
lie about receiving the Congressional
Medal of Honor you could face up to a
year in prison and uh also unfortunately
for him is that that meeting was
recorded So the FBI got a copy so he
gets charged and he goes before uh a
judge who's a former Marine who clearly
didn't find this very um very funny and
uh he ends up pleading guilty but agree
because there's no factual dispute that
he did this and uh but he reserves the
right to challenge the constitutionality
so he appeals it all the way up and it
goes to the US Supreme Court and the
court has a fractured opinion but six
justices agree for different reasons
that this is
unconstitutional because there's no
qualifier it basically says if you lie
you can go to prison and the court says
you know we're not going to say that all
falsehoods are categorically exempt from
the First Amendment and they have
different reasoning actually one of the
judges at the ninth circuit level has
had this amazing list of all the
different reasons why people lie like if
your spouse asks if that shirt looks
good on them if someone if that
Congressional Medal of Honor looks good
on them yeah if you're if you're trying
to get a Judicial clerkship you say
you're the greatest living jurist ever
um and that lies are part of life so if
the Sol of Valor Act had been I don't
know like tailored a little bit more
maybe it would have passed
constitutional muster well they actually
uh Congress at right after this Congress
passed a new stolen Val act that uh
basically ties it to fraud because fraud
is not something that is
constitutionally protected I love that
story partly because I I am an eagle
scout I was going to say I was an eagle
scout but if you earn the eagle rank
you're an eagle for life you can't it's
like being in the mafia you can't give
it back um but my uh award was given by
my Town's mayor in Middletown New Jersey
I don't even remember what year
thousands of years ago but uh the mayor
came and he had partly gotten into
office because he claimed to be an
Eastern Airlines pilot back when that
was an airline and that he had fought he
was like a fighter pilot in Vietnam and
then it came out shortly after I got my
award that he was like a baggage hatler
at East or something and so I always I
have a soft spot for people who steal
valer and did he get reelected uh no I
think he was kind of flush out and then
of course there's the uh the actor Brian
Dene was uh a Stolen Valor guy he was a
marine but he was out of the service
before Vietnam but claimed at various
points and I think this had something to
do when because he was in the first
Rambo movie First Blood where he plays a
uh police chief who runs John tries to
run John Rambo out of town but uh yeah
it was a big liar about it it's very
common actually yeah and I mean one of
Justice Kennedy's main rationals for
saying this is unconstitutional is he
said there's 3,500 people who have ever
received it there's only about 60 people
who are still alive The Government Can
more effectively use counter speech to
just have a and they do have a list of
everyone who's received it so if someone
says they've received the Congressional
Medal of Honor you just look at the list
and it's and you can tell they're
lying um whatever what happened to
Alvarez after that at Judo uh there
where is he now I you know I do not I I
tried to track him down for the book and
I could not so I'm not sure what he's
doing right now he's not in office right
now okay well you know but he could
stage a come back right I mean and and
it is fascinating for politicians
especially and obviously is at a low
level but many of them lie about their
service like I don't they tend not to
lie so grossly but you know I know
people like people talk about this all
the time with LBJ and Richard Nixon uh
for instance they all kind of padded
their service records in various ways
that alienated a lot of people I know
people like George McGovern and Eugene
McCarthy who were like real Bon and
actually George HW Bush who were real
Bonafide war hero types we're always
kind of pissed at Nixon and LBJ and
people like that yeah yeah and I mean
and Beyond just the the military aspect
anyone who I I covered Congress for a
few years and I would hear members of
Congress tell these ridiculous anecdotes
that you knew didn't happen to them and
you'd hear them if you covered them
enough you'd hear them tell it multiple
times and it would change just a little
bit depending on the context but there's
no way it could have happened but I mean
you're also not going to put them in
prison for it that would be crazy yeah I
don't know maybe there should be an
exception for Congressional lives but
talk more broadly about this concept of
misinformation because you know and
obviously the book goes deep on this
like that is often presented
misinformation and disinformation and
occasionally there's the term Mal
information is always presented as if
well this is a scientific category it's
like the you know it's like looking in a
microscope and you see a particular you
know germ or something but you know how
are people defining misinformation and
just how sloppy a concept is that so
it's a pretty fluid concept uh I mean
misinformation being you know things on
the internet are that that are not true
disinformation being more sort of
deliberate uh coordinated
campaigns um there's all all I I mean I
I think the best analysis of this Joe
Bernstein who's at the New York Times
now uh he I think it was about two years
ago he wrote a cover story for Harpers
that was really the first mainstream
outlet that challenged
this idea and I think his line was you
know the that there's these people from
like big nonprofits and Elite
universities who believe that they have
a special access to the fabric of
reality and they could Define what's
misinformation and I'm not saying that I
mean there's there's things on the
internet that are clearly false and I I
would not say that you know everything
is true or false depending on how you
look at it but this idea that you know
we can say with absolute certainty that
we know the truth or falsity of the
motives behind the circulation of this
and how people are interpreting it I
always think about it somewhat uh and
this is prob I I wouldn't ascribe this
to you but um you know when when you
things like uh you know is the dress uh
you know gold and black or blue and
brown or whatever there's a lot of
information in the world that is you
know and not many of the things that we
argue about the most are not really you
know that it doesn't make sense to talk
about it in terms of misinformation or
disinformation it's like actual
disagreements about kind of very basic
epistemological as well as ideological
concerns yeah and and I think I mean you
think about the lab leak Theory and I
mean the it it was considered absolutely
at least sort of by the mainstream
experts to be
misinformation that's evolved I I mean
and I think there's a spectrum because
if it's you know the vaccine has
microchips in it that it's easier to
assess that as being false uh than
theories about where it or originated
from um and well you you have a
particularly interesting uh section uh
where you're talking about um kind of
covid misinformation and um you quote
this became a huge kind of flash point
for reasons that are fascinating I think
despite wherever people end up on this
argument but where Anthony fouchy said
attacks on me are attacks on science and
then he's a guy who over time he had to
cop to the fact that like okay maybe he
was fudging stuff about the lab leak he
was fudging stuff about uh um wearing
masks the efficacy of that he fudged on
the percentage of the population that
needs to either be vaccinated or have
had covid to kind of create her immunity
so you have a guy who is claiming the
mantle of science you know and yet he
also has been caught repeatedly kind of
bullshitting people for Noble reasons
but still he's he's making stuff up
right yeah and I I think that when you
look at solutions to concerns about
misinformation outside of Regulation one
of the most effective ways is for the
government to build trust and uh a lot
of that involves just being blunt and
well and and also acknowledging what we
don't know and I I use the example of
Denmark their prime minister at the
earliest days of Co said you know
there's a lot we don't know and I'm
going to be as I'm going to be honest
and I'm going to tell you everything I
can but a lot of this is not is New
Territory for us and again that you know
I think rumbling behind a lot of this is
you know and again I I feel like people
have forgotten the Liber
liberatory dimension of the internet in
particular and you know it's it's I I
wouldn't paint it say starkly but you
know before and after the '90s because
the 9s also was the rush of uh cable TV
becoming a national phenomenon so
suddenly there were a lot of different
news sources or information sources the
internet certainly publishing became
cheaper everything became cheaper to
produce and consume and Gatekeepers you
know when there were three networks like
they hated the fox broadcast network
because suddenly okay that's competition
um you know and throughout Society like
Gatekeepers have really taken it on the
chin and I it feels to me like what's
rumbling through a lot of the attempts
to quell misinformation is an
unacknowledged sense of people who were
in charge now have a you know they have
to work they have to hustle in the
marketplace of ideas in a way that they
didn't have to in the past they do and I
also think in terms of Gatekeepers and
this is where I probably diverge the
most with sort of the political
conservatives is that I I think that the
social media platform should have the
independent uh opportunity to decide
whether they're going to block content
and this is where um there have been
some conservative efforts that have
really concerned me about saying You
must carry all this content I think and
thankfully those have mostly been either
struck down or or they're being held up
by well the fifth circuit uh upheld uh
Texas's law the the 11th circuit struck
down law and they're at the Supreme
Court this term uh I think it could be
disastrous if you basically say every
state has the ability to tell platforms
what they can and can't moderate because
the internet's going to be unworkable I
mean imagine what the Texas content
moderation law will be compared to the
California content moderation law um
you're not going to be able to have any
interaction between the states or I
don't know how You' Implement that so I
think the what I would like to see is I
mean there's a separate concern about
jawboning where it's government
officials coercing using the threat of
government which is is deeply worrying
but exactly but but I think that
Marketplace pressure of
basically social media platforms
determining what is in the best
interests of their consumers and what
what will bring them the greatest
rewards on the open market in terms of
moderating or not moderating I think
that should happen right and I think we
have threats to that system now do you
think on that score does there need to
be a kind of forced transparency like a
a legally enforced transparency on
how uh websites or services or platforms
actually you know do things or is it
something that that should also be left
to the marketplace that it worries me I
see the arguments for it but I mean
imagine uh requiring newspapers to post
their their daily editorial board
meetings and I I mean I I think think
that aren't we suffering enough exactly
yeah yeah um but it is to me it's always
worrying and I guess uh this is
somewhere uh Clarence Thomas seems to be
very outspoken about the idea that the
government can start calling balls and
Strikes on or or dictating terms of
social media platforms and yeah that you
know you see that on the right and then
you see versions of it on the left and
uh that can't end well it can and I mean
we had you mentioned Janet Reno and one
one of Janet Reno's legacies is Reno
vers ACLU which is a 1997 Supreme Court
case where the it's probably the best
internet law case out there it's where
the Supreme Court said struck down the
communications decency act and said um
the internet is not like a broadc
television it gets the full scope of
First Amendment protections and I think
these two sets of cases we have at the
Supreme Court right now both for the
sort of forced uh hands-off approach in
Texas and Florida as well as jawboning I
think that threatens the renover verse
ACLU precedent and it worries me because
I think the internet could look very
different after next June yeah which uh
you know that it it is deeply deeply
concerning even as it's good to know and
I think this came out with the Twitter
files and reason did a we had a cache of
uh material from Facebook showing how
tightly the Govern or aspects of the
government and aspects of these social
Med media platforms were
coordinating um covid coverage and kind
of tamping things down amplifying other
things Etc yeah and I think the jaw
boning is going to be it's going to be a
tough I I don't even know how the
opinion should precisely draw the line
because for the marketplace of ideas to
work you need everyone to be able to
participate in providing counter speech
including the government so I don't want
it to be where the government can't
respond to what it views as false it's
where the government is putting put
pressure on a social media platform and
saying and we saw this for years I mean
I I saw it just because of section 230
where you would have members of Congress
say you know we need to repeal section
230 because I don't like this
constitutionally protected speech that
we see on the internet and that that's
where I mean it's kind of like nice
section 230 you've got there it would be
a shame if something happened to it and
that that really worries me do you think
it's the type of thing where you know
people have gotten used too uh kind of
massive amounts of speech so they don't
remember what it was like or they don't
um you know or they don't have any sense
that like you know maybe they're not
always going to be the one who gets to
dictate what is allowed and disallowed
yeah I mean it's a lot of the sort of
pre pressure on the left to narrow the
First Amendment a lot of what I've been
dealing with as I've been doing
interviews about this book had been
people saying you know why you don't
care about author authoritarianism if
you cared about authoritarianism you'd
want to weaken the First Amendment and I
mean I kind of liken it to saying you
know you don't care about the spread of
fir so if you cared about it you'd get
rid of the fire department it's it makes
no sense right again with the fire
metaphors let's talk about some of the
solutions that you propose in the book
to deal with misinformation because it
is I mean it is true like there is you
know there is so much out there anybody
anybody can construct any narrative they
want like there's so much material out
there it's kind it's beautiful I mean I
I love it and I you know I'm old enough
to remember like what it was like when
you would try to find more sources and
it was just hard to do I uh uh at reason
in the 90s when we were all based in La
it's funny if you go back and you look
there's um we you know we this was pre
uh we didn't have access to Lexus Nexus
and we would sometimes go to the UCLA Li
Library where we had like a community
card so we didn't even have full access
there and they had four newspapers on
file it was like the LA Times the New
York Times the Christian Science Monitor
and maybe the Chicago Tribune and so
like if you look at reason stories up to
a certain point like we're always
quoting those four newspapers because
they're the only ones that were around
you know and it's like it was a shittier
world it was like a poorer impoverished
world it's so much better now but it is
true misinformation abounds so what are
um some of the ways that we address it
and I guess actually to uh come back to
a little bit what you were talking about
the Danish Prime Minister as well as the
case of fouchy you you do talk about how
governments need to act differently um
and you you kind of land on the idea
that they really need to be more honest
about what they do and don't know yeah
and that's always going to be difficult
because politicians want to spend things
to their political benefit but I think
the more
honest and the more trust that you can
build I mean that that will help prevent
sort of the total nonsense on the
internet from taking hold and there are
other solutions that I want to caution
first are not complete solutions to
misinformation which is an absurd
concept there's not I mean you you would
have to fix humankind and this idea that
we can ever fully address and and again
I mean there's certain stuff where you
know it's just like different
perspectives are going to persist for
good re I mean for understandable
reasons right what what is important
differs from person to person you uh
talk um uh briefly at least about the uh
the way that Johnson and Johnson which
in its own way is embroiled in you know
various kind of covid misinformation
things and whatnot but uh when Tylenol
was being um poisoned I guess right or
adulterated uh in was it 1982 I think uh
but you know a couple of people I mean
it was actually very few but there were
a couple of cases of where Tylenol had
been uh somebody had put cyanide in it
right on the Shelf people died from it
and you talk about how Johnson and
Johnson responded to that as kind of
exemplary could you rehearse that for us
yeah so I mean what Johnson and Johnson
did James Burke who was the CEO at the
time he was advised by all his lawyers
when PE when people were dying you know
you've got to just we we we've got to
put a wall around the company and not
say anything and he ignored the lawyers
which sometimes is not a great thing to
do sometimes it's a great thing to do um
and he did interviews and uh where he
was very candid and it it's seen sort of
in case studies to this day as one of
the best sort of corporate public
relations moves is to be honest and I
was actually just speaking at a legal
conference yesterday about a media law
conference and uh it was mostly defense
side but there was a um
plaintiff's lawyer one of the lawyers
who represented Dominion in the fox case
and she was making a really excellent
point that um what Dominion did which
was so effective was when all of the
falsehoods about it about its uh voting
machines was on Fox and the other
conservative media that they put out
tons of statements they sent out emails
fact sheets and that's very contrary to
the impulse of companies and lawyers but
I mean in part that really helped them
legally because then you can show actual
malice you kind of also a case where
like the marketplace of ideas and this
is particularly true on the left
although now that I think about it
Clarence Thomas has also called this
into question on the right like you know
there's this whole idea that the
marketplace of ideas is rigged uh you
know and it's like you know just like
Google isn't showing you what you want
to know like the marketplace of ideas is
we're being conned but there's
actually a lot of examples where oh you
know what like good information actually
chases out the bad exactly yeah I mean I
and it's never going to be a perfect
solution but I think that it I think it
can help quite a bit and it it doesn't
have all the negative side effects of
Regulation yeah um you talk also about
uh kind of media literacy and Civics
education particularly in K through 12
you know obviously I don't know why I'm
talking to you because I suspect that
you believe in compulsory schooling so
that is already you know there's a gulf
here but uh seriously talk what would
what would media literacy look like
because I I agree with you like we
should everybody should be treating
everything they read online essentially
as a deep fake you know that it's like
you don't want to have a complete hermen
hermeneutics of Suspicion but it's like
you know what you're reading is
interested in various ways that you may
not understand but like how do we get to
media literacy that is not not you know
a breath away from kind of a nihilism
yeah so I think that what it should not
be is the government saying this is the
truth this uh what it instead it should
be giving people the tools to make their
own assessments so if you see a claim on
social media that vaccines have
microchips how do you follow the trail
to credible sources um to to be able to
verify it and make your own assessment
and it's harder um then just sort of
saying okay I see something on the
Internet um how do you assess if you see
an indictment uh of whatever political
official your friend doesn't if your
friend forwards you an indictment of a
politician how might you look to see you
know was this actually what does that
look like I mean say you know uh I don't
know in fifth grade or something like
that what you know what would the
lessons be like would you use um I don't
know like case studies of like big
mistakes well I I think what you do is
give give the students a claim and say
uh say okay this is what you see on the
internet how do you how are you doing
research to see whether this is actually
true uh I mean just like the case study
method in law schools or Business
Schools at a much different level but
just showing people examples of how you
would do this do you think in general um
that we have a higher degree of media
literacy than we might have say 50 or 60
years ago
um I think it's it's just very different
because the media that you were
receiving uh that 50 years ago I think
that it it was from these centralized
sources um I think people probably
people definitely thanks to the internet
have more of an ability to verify what
they're seeing but there's also a whole
lot more to verify so it's it's very
different ecosystems I would like to
think you know is just that because
there's so many choices and because we
are bombarded with more I think a wider
range of viewpoints that people have a
sense that okay the information like you
really can't trust anything the way I'm
not sure anybody ever did but like you
know the you know classic Case of Walter
kronite um you know like it's it's
easier now to realize that Walter
kronite was kind of a horseshit artist
himself you know because we're there's a
million of him yeah um but uh what about
civic's education you talk about that
and I'm I'm curious uh how does that
kind of factor into this I think people
understanding how the government
operates so I mean understanding that
you know yes while the government does
have a lot of power there are C there
are certain
conspiracies that that proliferate on
the internet that just aren't happening
but if you have a basic understanding of
you know this is the oversight that
different agencies have this is what
Congress is capable of doing and this is
what the laws actually say this is how
the judicial judicial system works that
just understanding those structures I
think that helps people be a little more
skeptical of the sort of immediate
conspiracy theories on the internet
right and and I guess also maybe the
attempts to uh by the government or by
you know political power to you know
kind of restrict certain speech yeah
yeah exactly and I I I think that to I
mean c Civics education is just
important beyond the misinformation
debate so people can understand you know
why is it important to vote how I mean
what what are you voting for and what
how I mean when you I almost exclusively
vote against things but you know but
that's fine yeah yeah um could you talk
a little bit you have an interesting
career because you're now at Annapolis
or at the uh um the Naval Academy um do
they do they do you train lawyers there
or or are you doing like undergrad it's
undergrad so I teach uh Cyber Law and
First Amendment law for we have a cyber
operations major that about 10% of the
midshipman major and I also teach uh
constitutional law so the same sort of
law class that first year law students
get because are they receptive to your
kind of consistent um you know upholding
of the first amendment in light of kind
of government attempts to chip way at it
they are I mean they're I I think
teaching and obviously at the Naval
Academy we're very much more science
focused because we have a lot of science
positions but I can think of no more
important class than constitutional law
for future Military Officers because
they swear their oath the first and last
thing they get in my class is who are
you taking the oath to it's the
Constitution it's not a person it's not
an entity it is the Constitution so to
teach them what this document is so that
I mean they have very spirited debate
there's uh we have students from every
congressional district so there's just
this amazing diversity of backgrounds
that I don't think you really get at any
other
school uh where did you grow up uh in
New Jersey like you East that's right
yes yes so and how did you but you went
to Michigan as an undergrad I did I
wanted to go to a big school that was
far enough away from from East Brunswick
so you couldn't you know five miles down
the road to new Bron that was a little
too close yeah I got that I get that um
what uh what motivated you to go into
journalism uh so I was an economics
major but I was a writer and editor at
our daily student newspaper at Michigan
and I probably spent or not probably I
did spend far more time doing that than
actually in the classroom and it kind of
showed in my I was like that at the
daily Target record yeah yeah it was
just a lot of fun and I got intern ships
um my first one is was in mac and Island
Michigan they have a weekly newspaper
where the interns do everything from
writing to delivering the paper to
reading the paper I'm assuming as yeah
uh and then I in my final uh year final
summer I got an internship at The
Oregonian in Portland covering Tech in
their business section just sort of
right at the cusp of the.com Boom um and
this was when The Newsroom was probably
400 journalists um and so I was
fortunate enough to get a job offer and
it was a lot more fun than most of the
other economics Majors who were doing
consulting for deoe so do you worry
about or or you know I mean the
newspaper business in particular The
Daily newspaper business has been kind
of declining for decades and it doesn't
show any you know sign of turning around
uh you know does that wor you or how
does that wor you you how do you fit
that into a larger context of what media
is evolving into yeah I mean it's very
scary at the local level in particular I
mean the newspaper that I work for it's
still exists but it's a very small
fraction of the size of The Newsroom and
what that means is there's fewer people
looking at what local government
officials and even member of members of
Congress are doing and you don't and I I
think you there there are some bright
spots I live in Arlington Virginia and
we have a great local news site that is
self- sustaining and they they do good
work they're not the same size as a
local newspaper would have been but they
do great work and um you have good
nonprofit models like propublica I mean
I think some of the work they've done on
the Supreme Court has been very
essential uh but it concerns me and I
think you can't really look at
misinformation without looking at the
fact that you know you don't have as
much institutional news Gathering and it
always had flaws but you at least had
some sources that rigorously vet
information right and and if nothing
else they also produce the material than
that other people sift through I mean
this is one of the things that I've
always found kind of odd about um
particularly conservative critiques of
the New York Times like nobody is more
obsessed with the New York Times than
its conservative critics I they read it
like it's the Bible and they are just
you know constantly checking it so you
know it's kind of a win-win in that
sense uh why did you go to law school um
so I was I went to law school at night I
was at the oregonians Washington DC
Bureau when they had a DC Bureau and I
was really interested in writing about
legal issues and so I thought you know
I'll go to law school and maybe I'll be
a legal journalist and then I found that
I really enjoyed the actual practice of
Law and I had some experience they give
you hands-on experience in law school
and at the same time I kind of saw well
maybe newspapers are not the future want
talk a bit about your your legal uh
experience before you became a law
professor yeah so I clerked for two
federal judges uh from very different
political backgrounds uh uh judge l
brinka in the uh Alexandria federal
court in Virginia uh she is an amazing
judge she's a former prosecutor uh she
was appointed by Clinton she presided
over uh the zachar masawi the 20th
hijacker uh over his trial for I clerked
for her and um she really an amazing
mentor and then I went out to California
and clerked for a judge on the ninth
circuit um who is a George W bush
appointee uh milin Smith who also an
amazing judge who um both of them really
shaped me because they're both very
they're not politically leaning judges
so uh judge brinko would be really tough
on criminal defendants the what she said
to m during his sentencing um was
probably what she's best known for uh
she said you'll he tried to interrupt
her he had very little respect for her
in part because she was a woman and uh
she said you know you're you're going to
die without having a voice anymore
because of what you did and that was
very not what you would expect from
someone from a democratic appointee
perhaps um and judge Smith he actually
um before I clarked for him he wrote the
ninth circuit opinion in Alvarez finding
the law unconstitutional and he's um he
votes prob I would say probably as much
with the Liberals as the conservatives
which on the ninth circuit is pretty
rare so uh then I went to a law firm and
I practiced First Amendment law and
privacy and cyber security law and then
I came to the Naval Academy yeah and um
how long have you been at the Naval
Academy gosh eight years now yeah so it
seems to be working out well um just to
wrap up you know uh forecast wish cast
maybe um you know the Supreme Court uh
ruling that's coming up
about um you know the the ability of
platform social media platforms to kind
of run their businesses the way they
want to what do you think is going to
happen uh you know I I don't know what
will happen I know what I want to happen
I I want the Supreme Court to strike
down the Texas and Florida laws and also
set very firm limits on the ability of
the government to pressure platforms and
to moderate content so say you know
platform platforms uh can't be forced to
keep content up but they also can't be
forced to take it down unless it falls
into one of these narrow categories of
unprotected speech um whether that will
happen I I don't know I mean I I my best
guess is it's going to come down to
Justice's Kavanagh and Barrett uh I I
think they that you're making me feel a
little nauseous right well but I I think
that they're perhaps more in the Roberts
Camp of trying to maintain what the
current Supreme Court has been doing
obviously there are exceptions uh but
the current Supreme Court or for the
past 30 years has had some pretty robust
First Amendment rulings and I so I think
at least Roberts will be very cautious
about reversing that do you subscribe to
the uh idea and I've heard this
articulated by many people and you know
it's not particularly original but um
the person who told it to me in a way
that stuck with me was Mark tushnet who
is a you know self-described Marxist
jurist Etc but he said that you know in
the long run the Supreme Court isn't as
important as people either it's uh you
know um proponents or its critics think
and that it kind of is a little bit
ahead or behind Society
um but it's you know it it it it's not
the change maker it more it certifies or
kind of accelerates Trends um do you
think that's true and do you you know
and if so where do you think the
American people are on this question of
regulating online
speech well so I where the American
people are unfortunately is not great um
based on public polling in terms of the
first amendment in general there have
been some recent polls where um people
people the I think it's a majority now
would like to see more restrictions on
free speech and I think the Supreme
Court actually may be ahead of that and
uh and but it concerns me because the
Supreme Court does sometimes reflect
public opinion and I'm worried that uh
there's a lack of appreciation really
across the political Spectrum for the
really fundamental principles of the
First Amendment so it I and I think
globally we're really
heading toward this real recession of
free speech values and I I don't so I I
think frankly the Supreme Court may be
our best hope at this point yeah okay
well I hope it works out in the way that
we uh we both would be comfortable with
uh the book is liar in a crowded theater
freedom of speech in a world of
misinformation been talking to Jeff kasf
Jeff thanks so much not just for talking
to me but for I mean the books the shelf
of books that you're creating are just
like you know great thanks so
[Music]
much